welcome back to biomedical data science
and python let's start this lesson and
speak a little bit about data wrangling
how to load transform and start
exploring data
before we start let's discuss data
structures in python there are two
packages that are required to deal with
data that we load numpy and pandas numpy
is the fundamental library of python it
is used to perform scientific computing
it provides high performance
multi-dimensional arrays and tools to
deal with them a numpy array is a grid
of values of the same type let's say
numeric that are indexed by a tuple of
positive integers numpy arrays are fast
easy to understand and give users the
right to perform calculations across
arrays
pandas provides easy to use data
structures and data analysis tools for
manipulating numeric data organized as
data frames
the pandas data frame is a structure
that contains two-dimensional data and
its corresponding labels
data frames are very similar to sql
tables or the spreadsheets that you work
with in excel
in many cases data frames are faster
easier to use and more powerful than
tables or spreadsheets
as you can see in the first data set
that we will explore
the data contains four columns called id
flower tree and bird for each column
there are a number of specimens that are
rows in the table
each row and column have corresponding
cell values
to load the data set into the browser
console download the file to your
computer and then drag and drop it in
the area under the console where it says
drop a file